negli episodi precedenti di residenti vo
freschi arda madonna mi loro muoiono
quando reggono freddo è morta per avare
perché hanno figli proiettili mio
capriccio persia guarda me l'aspettavo
ei sexy una volta
io io io veramente non so come faccio a
essere viva mitica chi mi fa cadere da
200 metri e io continuo ad alzarmi ma
cosa ma cosa dove e morto
[Applauso]
questa questo è un bel finale c'è finale
di combattimento non avrò detto è morta
tipo 62 volte durante la e morta solo
adesso quindi figuriamoci mai più dire
una cagata inter l'ammazzavampiri o età
sarai tu bravo io non hanno mai fatto
niente facciali serpenti anche questo
cos'è sta roba qua chiarissimo trovato
qualcosa è stato parecchio divertente e
meno male che ho finito con colpi
d'avanzo perché la con e sport al flaco
perché prima che si incontra qualcuno
domanda di coltello che non avevo più
niente meno male che è rimasto qualcosa
rose cercar osmica ragazzi è stato
bellissimo
e stata una bellissima battaglia ci
siamo finalmente a devo spaccare il look
posso sparare al lucchetto secondo voi
senza sprecare corpi sono messi però lo
sprecare un colpo di dai colpi doppietta
per sta merda ma non facevo il coltello
mais il coltellino per staccarlo che non
funziona mai nella vita ma quasi
va bene mi mancava entrare nelle caverne
era un po che non lo facevo min chiamate
miranda ragazzi mancano due per sono tre
i tre boss quello col martello più
piccolo quello col martello più grande e
poi manca la zia ma terminata correndo
di mezzanotte si innalza sua lineri
mentre che la vecchia questa linea
noi attendiamo l'estrema luce nella rete
nella morte dell'area
vermeer mario meno questa non è un bosco
sono quasi morto in quel castello
se non vuoi morire su una succede
abilità diglielo essere quasi mai e sono
caduto da 26 metri secondo di più forze
sai cosa intendo vendono ancora trovato
rosa dove l'ha portata a madrid perché
c'era già da rendere servile
magari quasi troppo dai dai sono ancora
in tempo di migliore la zia pensa
cristinziano una vita per una vita
ok razza di stronzate medieval basso
reno bambina fosse normale millenni dei
quattro casati il sentiero che c'è gli
emblemi pianti di parlare per iniqui
voglio solo trovare mia figlia non so se
lei vista zio non è che parla normale
c'è una così non avevo nessuno se non
conosci la risposta non ho mai capito
che cosa cia da ridere questa ma va bene
via galata ho trovato una chiave alata
ottimo non ho ben capito cosa me ne devo
fare però a ok ok ok basta che torna
questa roba qua mi apre un sacco di roba
e anche nel villaggio nel villaggio
c'era un sacco di roba con per possa
fare qua mi teoricamente se ci torno
adesso non sono anche qui dove sto
andando ormai vago bellissime se forti
così comunque non ho mai capito metti
una maniglia è uguale luogo della
cerimonia o è questo interagisci michela
e l'umbrella questo questo simbolo mi
ricordavo ecco è l'umbrella mi ricorda
devo rifare il quadro che c'è lì dentro
sicuro devo riportarlo in qualche modo
proiettando non lo so però devo trovare
coso per da posizionare la sua questi
sforzi non ho minchia gli stronzi
pacchetto visto è guarda mazzo già prima
posso
luca cecchino ha dato anche il trofeo
meno male che lo zio per favore dai per
cortesia etichette lo chiedo per
cortesia sono riuscito avanzarono faccio
pagare sono riuscita mancarlo da un
metro e quello che ho preso da un
chilometro ma possibile un po di
coerenza nella mia vita vi prego giorno
scarpi arrugginiti potrò creare dei
proiettili si incazzi proprio fluido
chimico la porta del villaggio ecco la
ragazza adesso vi ricongiunge eccolo qui
credo
vediamo specie dal pozzo tutte quelle
robe lì no lunghezze proprio io penso di
sapere le cose ma non le so cos'è sta
roba
salve pagina il mio amico proprio lui è
stato inutile nei sei nato con lo usi
anche come ci aveva provato qualcosa di
prezioso
ho trovato un flacone è un valore ma
manca il coltello che mi casca da quello
che hai tra le mani e proprio tua figlia
minchia uguale lavori cresciuta a
guardare un po meglio ma che senso c'è
mia figlia l'ha dentro testa
ma no alla nostra scatola testa che
cazzo rini tu ma come no no non buttarla
che però poi flacone è contenuta la sua
testa è quindi è morta l'hanno staccata
rosa non azzardarti a dirlo non è
possibile foto dopo la doverosa dallo
spirito di tua figlia e del tutto
intatto possiede dei poteri straordinari
ci potrebbe mai farlo è quelli che ti
hanno fatto prima tutte quelle cose
salvarla da questo sei fuori di testa è
tua figlia che fuori di testa va bene
mai a trovare l'uomo che vive lì poi
potremo proseguire questa con da grazie
duca gentile altro tempo e dimmi subito
tutto
non c'è nulla che ti obblighi a fidarti
di me ma ai delle alternative ragazzi di
vista simpaticissimo ditemi quello che
volete ma lo adoro è veramente troppo
silva è l'unico simpaticoni residenti il
cliente ha sempre ragione
dopotutto quindi ho la testa di mia
figlia ve divertente se stai mentendo la
pagina e molto costa troppo quale faccio
per prima cosa munizioni pistola sia
perché sono finito anche quelli del
fucile non per cortesia perché veramente
sono fiato ma quindi le luci la
precisione sai che ma si danno i
problemi interessante va bene os aprirle
tutte ste forte per favore anche la pro
tutte faccio prima questa che come non
va bene qua a quattro ali
c'è pure la chiave con quattro ali
addirittura fanno pure gli schizzinosi
due ali va bene tutto sto casino e siamo
ritornati qua va bene al mio dio allora
ho lasciato un miliardo e mezzo
di cose nel villaggio un miliardo da
prendere
quarante in collezionato ho lasciato
anche ai licantropi sempre questo a casa
si è completamente distrutta non posso
entrare una cooper spaglio peccato
vedere se era rimasta viva la zia
munizioni pistola però quanta roba come
punizione esclusiva ma dove
cosa posso usare come ace lanciagranate
ma dove nuova bellissima star o la pace
anche questo c'è un tesoro con lanari
luisa minchia che dispiace è remo che è
morta vabbè però quando mi ci fai
rientra peccato perché qua mi dava rosso
potevo vedere se potevo volevo vedere se
fatto prendere qualcos'altro munizioni
magnum con temi storici sono ancora da
trovare il tuo gioco
vabbè ragazze trovato un sacco di
munizioni però sono contento l'ex grado
da via web che cazzo c'è un computer ma
che è arriva al sito nessun segno di
winter's base stabilità nella chiesa
ispezione nel laboratorio ingresso nella
fabbrica rose winters e di the winter's
r v quindi sono quelli della quindi e
chris quel bastardo de merda che
arrivato qua lo so che noi mitas che
lasci che lasci il portatile così massei
pirla che lo portano subito
non credo che il problema principale di
questo posto sia forte riportati lì però
di uno dei temi che a c'è ancora il
cancello ad un utente
c'è una vita che ci sto cancello qua non
ho mai visto cosa c'è dietro la
spacchiamo tutto sto casino e potevo
farlo fuori col coltello sta roba
cosa c è fatto qua dietro una foto bella
luca guarda fuori dalla finestra che
senso 04 amici concordi 07 04
porca [ __ ] qui sotto sorella quella
bella
ce ne sono due una brutta ma anche
l'altro torto che dichiara quanto sei
bello tu io devo usare il coltello
perché non lo faccio per risparmiare
proiettili lo stato non muoia e allora
la bamboo la solita non usate il
coltello in soggiorno non serva un
castaldo non muoiono 07 04 è la mia data
di nascita tra l'altro non so per quale
motivo l'hanno messa ma bene e ci sarà
eccolo qua 0 amiche un core i7
c'è un altro c'è un altro codice
numerico che non vedo anzi non 70 fatto
ok 07 04 08 07
ecco ora i my blog una pista ho trovato
una pistola che come faccio una pistola
manovella del crif per spostare il
trattore benissimo bene ma non me li
devo anche capire a cosa mi serve sta
visto l'acqua che hanno già una o due
anzi due
una pistola completamente automatiche
canzoni ciò che tanto fa schifo di danno
160 di danno vedevo la mia moto fa
no no no no no no per favore fate di
scarsi vostra terra davanti a monte che
a valle
tutto a posto tutto il cranio che si
dammi tutto grazie gentile
vediamo se riesco arrivare in quel
[ __ ] posto col camino che mi stanno
allontanando cacchio fatto un giro
incredibile e non ha ancora raggiunto
ora galliera che ha pure ripa ste cagate
io mi ricordo che quel giro c'era quello
gigante col martello quale abbiamo
neppure loro dico se spunta quello non
lo faccio fuori manco morto
quello è un boss per forza se non grassa
e morì quanto ci va bene va bene
benissimo perfetto ok abbiamo fatti
fuori quasi tutti tra l'altro che c'è
veramente c'erano un miliardo all'inizio
però li ha fatti portare almeno 20 li ho
fatti fuori quindi chiuso proprio testa
a [ __ ]
questo è grosso cazzo face di salutarvi
qui che a questo è grosso raga
questo è giustissimo il solo far fuori
con quel fucile wolverine in te che
cazzo nome che è possibile
tocca così grosso
minchia non muore manco morto un po
strano da dire e morì minchia questo
gigantesco è morto
l'amore ma da quanto tempo per carica
madonna che è lento che sei tranquillità
ma questo non muore sono scaricate un
miliardo questo era grossissimo laga
cranio cristallizzato perfetto perfetto
un gas aver sparato 62 mila proiettili
c'è qualcosa qui questo era grosso forte
raga va bene sbagliato chiara stava di
ferro proprio lui ma che minchia ragazzi
quanto aveva fatto
faccio una sfida la cosa c'é qua dentro
ci sono un po di soldi ruota nel fosso o
o una ruota il per aprire un po 10 sono
un sacco tra l'altro meno male almeno
posso vedere posso prendere oggetti o
cose così pronta del pozzo lo vado a
mick eccola 12 anni poi arriva qua
dentro
segui cavo almeno sblocco la porta nova
spetta a me troppo dentro che vabbè
entro il giorno mi hanno invitato è sono
entrato perché mandati di venire qua
vedo che non è proprio affabile il tizio
giorno devo mi sa che è morto quello che
devo incontrare dai fermo
caccavalle mica qualcosa figura è durato
successo qua cava che apre tutto alla
chiave sacrificate due capre a madrid
iran da cazzo ne frega a me la chiave la
ta è solo un pezzo sono necessari altre
parti e fin qua ho capito eccolo mentre
del premio combinato con la chiave sotto
tutti la chiave a quattro ali e the
majlis merda meglio tornato il sì ma ci
dormo citò già messo un'ora per arrivare
qua ma ce l'ho fatta
munizioni pistole fresco cella
cataclisma fuori scommettete qualsiasi
cosa c'è fuori quando sento preso tutto
si guarda vorrei casino ancora no amen
ce l'abbiamo fatta ora mantiene la
parola e dimmi che diamo mi dice che lì
saranno ti agitare prima usa quella
chiave trova tutti i fratelli è anche
casa è un puzzle fai anche col padre di
rosa e in totale sono anche palle uno è
già tuo il resto è nelle mani degli
altri siti ma basta quanta gente lo fa
fuori ci sono gli alti signoria di
signori su quello che il martello adoro
e miranda e la retta e spietata sovrana
del villaggio al suo servizio street 4
un buon la sua signora siam pazzi
hai già incontrato la prima ed inedita è
a rischio poi c'è l'altro col cappello
la seconda vive in una valle energia
minchia lei è alice di bambole era
dimenticato di questa mano nessuno è mai
riuscito a fare ritorno dalla sua oscura
è secondo me nessuno è mai entrato
proprio cazzo entrato là dentro
il terzo è moro ha già vincente sembra
che vero significato completamente ci
fose dei mulini gira la voce che non sia
lui l'unico mostro ad abitare quelle
anno
va bene e poi c'è quello c'è quello col
martello ultimo nonchè il più pericoloso
lavora in una fabbrica ai confini del vi
e quello grosso col martello scherzer
cosa lavora io li chiamerei abomini che
vanno oltre l'umana immaginativa bene
allora il suo volo col martello l'ha
fatto lui come i puzzle eva per amato
quanto è quanto è lungo sto gioco rega
mamma mia
chi può suonare la roma che ci sei tu la
vita a macinare di enti di alta qualità
e cosa la cucina del tu ma cosa esce
alle erbe aumenta la tua salute di un po
permanente finissimo 43 vai dagli studi
del volo da lì ne abbiamo recuperato
tutti maisky a destra buonissimo stop
esce alle erbe e m'ha fatto lui
mettiamoci cornello va bè ragazzi il
gioco dell'anno
bellissimo anche la componente cucina
ricette dalle casse pesce l air berlin
cooking mama diventata andiamo a vedere
che vogliono sti signori qua ma comunque
a prescindere da questo ragadi
torniamoci che dobbiamo seccare
qualsiasi animale
ecco questo è già secco però non è un
animale e vedi qua c'è bisogno di salute
il nome momento a madonna di bio
garanzia però giorno sento dei rumori
sinistri essere sincero non fanno finché
non succede niente
quando c'è niente corvi tutto tutto
allegro meno ma almeno almeno allegro
sto posto cordi e basta a sinistra c'è
un ponte beh almeno il ponte è stabile
almeno quello ecco infatti meno ma
eccoli gli altri che sono finiti meno
male che fa parla se crolla mi fa solo
un favore meno moglie qua e là
cosa grazie ma che gentile ma quelle mia
moglie e mia moglie quel porro e te
vieni con me ho qualcosa da dire
sono sicuro che raimi lusi no e infatti
non lo era per niente succede
minchia questa qua ti entra nei pensieri
che roba è tipo psico mantis basta fare
rimettere in internet al via basta ok
c'è un angelo non è mangiato senza di te
è morta e dobbiamo trovare i paesi da
fessi sì sì sì adesso li troviamo un
addio che mi sta succedendo e ambiente è
vita che lei chi entra nel pensiero dopo
mi abbandonano tutti mailat a sei morta
fa sei morta tua amica no no no sei
morta più proprio quindi sono cazzi tua
amica mia e cos'è una tromba giga
bellissimo un sacco un altro comunque
raga comunque che ha dubbi è caduto il
coltello a benevento va bene sì sempre
sicuramente sta impazzendo comunque la
cosa che volevo dire il coltello che mi
è cascato quello di estremo valore no
dove cacchio morì figlio perché quello
valeva un sacco non si apre così la
rinuncia ai tuoi ricordi ti picchia
stavolta che cielo dall'inizio e metteva
nella buca delle lettere
ce l'avevo dall'inizio sta vuoto non mi
serviva a niente se non a questa cosa ma
si apre sta succedendo che sia alla
ripiglia equa ma dietro non vorrà
riprendere va bene lasciarli va bene o
meno male che almeno la sala la pulite
perché ha invitato va in bagno per sport
un'ala stati di salone
e sempre bello pulirlo cosa qua cioè che
fate affare interno nasce il sole qua
come come centrato un ascensore in stop
o lo sapete solo voi come centrali non è
possibile sta cosa cismar manca solo ci
manca solo che sfarfalla la luce guarda
secondo me con whitney ethan vieni da me
ok sto arrivando infatti perché ci mette
un po ci mette un po ma arrivò se
tranquilla zia si è aperta per telefono
allora nel telefono le cose
dell'accensione va bene la zia la vedo
un po dura qua è però secondo ecco la
madonna che bello minchia e anch'io
voglio vivere vicino alla cascata e figo
che invidia
ecco fateli bernice ray un attimo il
muro esterno però è bella almeno quello
casa benevento
buongiorno sono luogo dalle 8 dita se
volete farvi non solo
benvenuto beh ma è bellissimo è vera
scusatemi è proprio bella è proprio
carina se fosse tenuta bene sarebbe
ancora me però è proprio bello la casa
complimenti e non si dà il benvenuto
allo zio ma poi ci voleva la testa
dell'alce dell'altra casa mia da vado ci
sarà una boxe fight bella caput aquae
adesso poi è una mia madonna ma che figo
e bellissima stacca mi piace proprio la
casa non ci vivrei mai pure bello a
vedersi vedere l'altro l'altro l'altra
stanza va bene secondo me i ragazzi sarà
una boss fight dove dovrò correre per la
casa perché la vedo è troppo non c è
troppo ben curate non c'è niente
un'altra scelta quanti casa
licenziamenti in casa machine solo
ascensori facciamo ce l'abbiamo chiamata
nella ditta di ascensori abbiamo fatti
mettere 86 poi in posti che non hanno
senso perché avevo bombe prova va bene
cioè il piano interrato
minchia titanic i titani paul acqua cioè
ciò anche la cascata dei fuori vedi che
tutto torna attenzione
minchia bellissimo il cinema cioè la zia
ma non c'è ragazzi ci sono stanze in
orbi e non c'è niente magliette proprio
luce nulla completamente non c'e neanche
tipo colpi niente di cielo aperto 26
armadio trovatore non c'è nulla o riempì
la casa di proiettili dopo perché non ha
senso che abbiano fatto tutto sto casino
e poi non c'è
ma in casa completamente vuota ma se
come sembra
[Musica]
e anche oggi i ragazzi finisce
l'episodio di rese di un chilo
spero che vi sia piaciuto ci vediamo
domani come sempre con il prossimo
iscrivetevi al canale lasciato un bel
commento qua sotto cioè beh come un
commento un commento
fate quel che volete bene ci vediamo al
prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]